what the business like why would you
ever do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gosh
hey what is this why does this exist why
is there a marshmallow
I'm rational supposed to go not but this
is how she served a is this what it look
like oh well what is it supposed to look
like this is inspired by Filipino movies
I'm gonna eat it just for the sake of
not having to look at it the rule number
one everything needs to be aesthetically
pleasing alright you want me to eat this
so I eat just like the whole marshmallow
and then a little bit it's gotta be
marshmallow first see I feel like I need
to divide this marshmallow up okay that
looks better right I guess I'll try it
[Music]
it tastes like a hotdog with sugar on it
that's not the flu combination I
actually kind of liked it savory and
sweet actually pretty good it's not the
worst thing ever
almost I give up a hot dog bun we're
like really sugary it's a way more
offensive to look at then to you this
does not scream rich by any means
maybe her kid like loves this and they
like went to the Philippines and they
had this whole Air Show is the best
thing ever mom make this for me on my
birthday hey if I do we eat this I would
need anything ask kids did save me and
going out to lunch which others
to do marshmallow it's like a hot dog on
marshmallow
maybe kisses actually liked it though
like what's not to like to mean you're
like seven years old a hot dog
marshmallow Ivanka Trump what compelled
her to be like yeah we should just multi
pop any what are you gonna put the whole
thing here mouth at once with it that's
trifling itself
[Music]